let's bring in our diplomatic editor
dominick waghorn um and dominic
um the news that everyone had been
waiting for
free but not quite free
yeah it's quite murky and uh it has to
be said the nazanin story has been murky
all the way through really her five-year
sentence which was uh due to come to an
end uh today and the expectation was
that she wouldn't be released today
because the signals hadn't been given by
the iranians
that this was imminent the foreign
office hadn't really been given any
indication that they should prepare for
her
reception for instance and her family
hadn't been told that either
so i think expectations have been
managed but then we had this sort of
flurry of excitement
with a reuters agent news agency uh wire
flash saying that
the lawyer her lawyer had been told or
have been quoted at least on an iranian
website as saying that she'd been
had her electronic tag removed and she
has been freed
that was her how her lawyer put it in
tehran or was quoted to have done so
on on this website um but then it's uh
it seems that i haven't been able to be
in touch
get in touch yet with richard radcliffe
um who's nasally's husband obviously
all the campaign team who have been
working for years now to get nazanin
released but he has been talking to his
uh
mp the family mp uh tulip sadiq and
she has been tweeting saying the
following thankfully her ankle tag has
been removed her first trip will be to
see her grandmother
less positive she has been summoned once
again to court next sunday so
it sounds like bittersweet news really
from tehran on the on the one hand yes
her tag has been removed
and the background to that is she had
her tag put on her a year ago when she
was released from prison
along with thousands of other prisoners
because of coronavirus nazarene zagari
ratcliff was allowed out of jail after
four years in in pretty terrible
conditions in
various iranian jails she was allowed to
go home back to her parents in tehran
but she had to wear this electronic tag
and which is she was subject to
surveillance and harassment by iranian
authorities throughout those 12 months
the news today is that she's had that
tag removed
and i think that's obviously that that
reuters news flash raised hopes
that the best was about to come that she
was about to be
released particularly with her lawyer
saying she has been freed
all we can say at the moment is she's
been freed of her electronic tag
and i think the concern is if she's
going back to court next week
then there's this whole specter of extra
charges being brought against nazi and
sagari ratcliffe
which were raised a few months ago and
because of a human cry diplomatically
and from other pressure those charges
weren't applied in this
case but it seems she's going back to
court then the authorities have thought
again